can't wait for street fighter 5 full  release in February don't get your black  belts in a twist you'll get another  chance to preview the game very soon  players who pre-ordered capcom's latest  brawler will have access to a new beta  from 1201 am December eighteenth through  10pm December twentieth like the last  beta ps4 and pc owners the light can get  in on the action and play together both  ranked and casual matches will be  available that we don't know who will be  on the character roster just yet in any  case it'll be another opportunity to  sharpen your V skills and critical arts  street fighter 5 releases februari 16th  following launch players will be able to  unlock six additional characters in game  or via season pass for more Street  Fighter 5 updates and announcements keep  it locked at gamespot.com i'm tony  wilson you can find me on twitter a  chain gun pope and i'll be over here  practicing my yoga fire